c'était un
c'est l'année de tous les espoirs pour
l'om après sa victoire en coupe de la
ligue et le club est à deux doigts de
devenir champion de france
à l'opposé sa réserve n'a jamais connu
une telle saison elle est menacée de
relégation en dh n'a pas on n'est pas le
résultat mais se retrouve un dh
l'entraîneur michel flos a été limogé à
quatre matches de la fin du championnat
l'équipe descendez ce serait une
catastrophe pour les joueurs c'est le
foot c'est la première année que je le
métier avec cinq divisions d'écart il
aurait alors peu de chances de passer
trop avec l'ol
qu'est-ce que catastrophique de
dessalement dh avec un centre de
formation pour le niveau donnant un
complexe qui peut mater un centre de
formation qui aurait quant à lui
beaucoup de mal à tirer les futures
perles du football
hélas
courir
égaliser
c'est m
là
il faut égaliser
je
gala il faut légaliser une belle
première mi temps dans laquelle je
souhaitais qu'on marque plus de buts
parce qu'on appelle un vrai
c'est une occasion de but mais bon
aujourd'hui l'essentiel est fait ce
qu'on était venu chercher cinq points et
l'abeille faut continuer maintenant on
va penser au prochain match
le prochain match à grasse s'attendait à
un match difficile aussi à l'extérieur
cette dépense beaucoup plus difficile
que celui ci ce sera à l'extérieur si
grave ce jour la deuxième place et
difficile
la réserve est vite une nouvelle fois la
descente le match contre grasse se
soldera par un match nul l'équipe
n'ayant pas pu ramener les points de la
victoire
elle devra obligatoirement s'imposer
lors de ses deux prochaines rencontres
une défaite ou un nul serait synonyme de
descente en division d'honneur
m
c'est la fin de la saison
l'aboutissement de toute une année de
championnats
c'est aussi le moment d'être fixé sur
son avenir au sein du club
ici ça donne un cocon et quand on sort
de là c'est la vie active s'est il faut
si on n'a pas réussi si on n'est pas
donner cette formation d'après là c'est
faux les dates des clubs amateurs pour
rebondir il faut se laver les affaires
il faut aller travailler il faut voilà
il faut aller s'entraîner le sort alors
que la ici on s'entraîne le matin
l'après-midi il il ya les installations
donc c'est sûr que de partir d'ici dans
les derniers clubs amateurs ou non un
club pro où il ya pas trop de structures
là c'est la difficulté est là on touche
du doigt et on se dit peut-être que si
j'avais été si j'allais revenir en
arrière plus que j'aurais fait plus
d'efforts un moment donné parce que des
fois certains mais malheureusement c'est
la facilité et puis voilà moi nous on
est là pour leur faire comprendre que
c'est ça parce que par le travail que
s'ils ont la chance de passer avec les
pros ça continue puis sinon la vie
continue aussi mais cette année l'om
tarde à prendre les décisions
le club attend en effet les résultats de
l'équipe réserve
une descente en division d'honneur
pourrait influencer ses choix
pour alexander la saison est terminée il
s'est blessé
c'est moins grave que nico mais il ne
pourra pas soutenir ses camarades lors
des prochains matchs par contre il
connaît la décision de l'om à son égard
son père est venu du gabon à la demande
de roland gransart il a une bonne
nouvelle alors annoncé alexander va
signer son premier contrat pro tu as eu
la chance d'intégrer à 17 ans le groupe
pro qui a montré des qualités pour y
rester et il ya eu le bonheur de faire
quelques apparitions en équipe première
notamment dans les coupes ce qui à 17
ans est relativement exceptionnel dans
le monde du foot et plus
particulièrement à l'om tous les retours
que j'ai sur toi surtout sur le
comportement nous sommes positifs ce qui
fait que tu vas changer de statut avec
tout ce que cela comporte sur sur les
aménagements notamment financiers mais
c'est pas le plus important
savais qu'à un gamin se retrouve dans un
milieu avec les pros qui ont leur façon
de vivre qui dépense qui ont des
comportements
c'est difficile l'influencent de
l'environnement immédiat et il faut
qu'ils restent concentrés n'a pas encore
franchi ce palier faut pas qu'ils se
dispersent faut pas qu'ils se comportent
comme
comme si comme s'il y était déjà donc
c'est ça le plus difficile en fait c'est
qu'ils se disent ça y est j'y suis or
c'est pas encore le cas moi ce que je
veux te dire en conclusion messi que tu
as tout ce qu'il faut pour jouer en
appui de marseille
kato et je voudrais pas que que dans six
mois lui moi tu fasses un parcours entre
prête à elles deux people
et même si ça peut être un parcours
formateur moi je pense peut-être tout ce
qu'il faut pour thème imposé ici nous et
c'est assez de se la jouer à la pro et
tout me bats en restait toujours humble
le savoir de ne pas oublier d'où on
vient quoi ça fait plaisir d'être aisés
à investir avec autour de soi des
gabriel adam de morientes des grands
joueurs et deux pour repreneur exemple
ces
ce formidable jeu pas m'en plaindre
c'est
tout marseille et réunis ce soir pour le
match à deux journées de la fin du
championnat l'om peut prétendre au titre
en cas de victoire contre rennes 18 ans
que toute la ville attend cette
consécration alors c'est l'événement
majeur
gbagbo
mais ce sera pire
on vient
alexander et jordan ne joueront pas ce
soir mais si l'om gagne ils seront eux
aussi champions de france ça pour nous
le championnat gagné le championnat ça
une autre dimension encore c'est autre
chose
je vois la différence entre gagner une
coupe c'est pas que c'est facile de
gagner une coupe c'est très dur mais le
championnat c'est extrêmement difficile
parce que ça se joue sur 38 journées
débats des eaux des moments où dans
l'année vous prenez des claques eu des
moments où vous avez la presse qui vous
tapez des moments très durs
et quand vous avez cette partie où là on
est à trois matchs donc c'est fini dans
15 juin vous dites mais ça ne nous
arrive pas mais comment m
j'espère le vivre là je vous dirais
comme ça j'espère le vivre parce que je
me dis que après coup si on est
champions après coup double et partir
simplement
lorsque l'on est spectateur d'un match
de foot on est captivé par cette
histoire de ballon des pieds de torse et
de tête
c'est certainement parce que durant les
90 minutes d'un match on vit toute la
gamme des émotions que l'on peut
ressentir durant toute une vie la joie
la souffrance la colère l'angoissent
l'admiration
le sentiment d'injustice
mais pour éprouver pleinement ses
émotions encore faut-il être supporters
quoi de plus insipides en effet qu'une
rencontre sans enjeu où l'on ne se sent
pas appliquée
et quand vient enfin le décisif de la
victoire on en arrive à hurler sa joie à
travers la ville a embrassé un inconnu à
qui on dira à peine au revoir une fois
la partie hachée
sicaud par pelé platini maradona ronado
ou zidane ou fascine c'est bien sûr en
raison de la qualité de leurs exploits
mais aussi parce que nous avons la
certitude que dans le sport
les rares à atteindre la gloire ils
parviennent par leurs propres forces
et non parce qu'ils ont eu la chance
d'être né au bon endroit au bon moment
tous égaux ou presque face à l'effort et
à la réussite
jamais vécu un moment comme ça alors
jeté la jeune garde et les sillages et
epeat l année dernière juste une suite
aux nationaux là je me retrouve sur le
droit mais doux
sur trois est bon
c'est énorme on
salut
très bonne expérience pour moi pas
depuis à 18 ans en france prend aussi
ses parts à la finalité
effectivement la victoire de l'om ne
doit pas faire oublier la situation
périlleuse dans laquelle se trouve
l'équipe réserve
aujourd'hui jordan se rend au match
contre furiani
même si sur le papier celui ci est
champion de france à 18 ans la défaite
de l'équipe réserve remettrait en cause
l'avenir de cette génération de joueurs
ils arguaient ce qui se passe si vous
gagnez part au match
des 100 dh division d'honneur
c'est pas
un club comme l'olympique de marseille
ce soir
d'être déjà en conservant pensais
beaucoup
et
mais le maintien en cfa 2 6
c'est compliqué quand même
mais bon
déjà l'objectif ses pattes et son
montage après l'année prochaine des
enfants précisant
on verra
les gars y en a qui vont faire leur vie
une action peut-être propre à pro eleec
gerland matters terrain qu'ils
arrêteront ils travailleront les gars
mais voilà on a passé un an sans jouer
matt nuls puis plus de temps avec lou
ans a passé plus de temps semble qu'avec
nos familles les gars et ni de l'ancien
président a émis deux contrats et
marchés
ça va être une autre collègue ce qu'on
fait le ballon les gars jouent depuis
que telle et puis c'est un public jeune
avec les collègues c'est ça c'est ces
moments c'est pour ça qu'on plonge ou
tegra que son bled à mes yeux en fin de
saison
quand je vois le gars a tout donné on
est amusé mais aussi maintenu ses parts
non sur des dalles et je suis verra dans
la rue dans dix quinze ans on
s'embrassera avec plaisir que les tout
donné tous les mecs les remplaçants
mixte eu l'air ceux qui jouent pas ce
que je souvent pas souvent l'école et
tout donner on donne pour alors
aujourd'hui les cailloux vient d'ouvrir
on doit mettre l'agressivité qu'il faut
le continent raison agressive agressive
- quart d'heure ils sentent que
aujourd'hui dans votre regard dans vos
interventions souvent si vous deviez
citer rien pour rien après impôts au
caire
vraiment
josé anigo est présent pour l'occasion
il sait que le match d'aujourd'hui est
un match couperet
ce n'est pas seulement la relégation que
joue cette équipe mais c'est
certainement leur carrière de
footballeur qui nous ont oubliés les
occasions sont nombreuses mais la
pression semble trop forte
l'équipe perd ses moyens et furiani
ouvre le score en première mi temps
même s'il arrive à construire de bonnes
actions l'équipe manque de réalisme face
au but adverse
et
finalement en fin de partie la réserve
obtient un penalty qui peut lui
permettre de revenir au score
micron pas des simples mots pour pas
nécessaire alors moi et bien vision
d'horreur
quelle ironie pour certains de ces
jeunes d'alterner dans une période si
courte
un titre de champion de france et une
descente en division inférieure deux
extrêmes qu'ils croiseront certainement
de nouveau à l'avenir a condensé
inattendu de toute une carrière en
quelque sorte
mon père aussi en jeu
m
le nouveau départ
par essence attention
j'étais dégoûté parce que ne sais pas
imaginez-vous l'équipe première
championne de france et la réserve en dh
c'est pas une bonne chose
un bon
si vite et je ne veux pas regarder tel
visa d des dirigeants bientôt
et j'ose y est
tiens grand saule je n'arrive même pas
les frais d en face ça pas bien tu vois
il sait chanter sans que fruits trois
m'ont fait confiance et tout mais rien
pas terroriste en concert
c'était seulement
c'est un pas omettre ma tête
une carte de visite quand on voit une
descente de cfa2 en dh dont fait partie
de cette équipe là notre carte de visite
elle est un peu et un peu bafouée quoi
elle est un peu allez l est pas très bon
en quoi donc les clubs ils font
attention à ça ils regardent et puis
tout le monde le sait partout en france
on sait que l'équipe réserve descendue
en dh donc dès qu'on rencontre une club
avec ça fait partie des qui veut dire
qu'il s'engage donc sais c'est pas très
bons et ses mauvais et puis voilà quoi
donc
après si on reste à l'om on a une chance
de se rattraper en mon talent d après
mes joueurs qu'ils ne restent pas à l'om
qui sommes qui sont qui sont virés ou
alors que alors qu'ils n'ont pas envie
de rester
c'est toujours difficile après de
trouver un club qui compte deux jours
qui distingue en dh parcelle ac real
après tout c'est la caresse l'autre avec
un jeu indé h et 80
un tiers tandis que ses parents c'est
pas pareil moi j'ai peur
j'étais ma perle
aux stéréotypes on va dire le métier de
footballeur mais qui court derrière un
ballon et qui gagnait dans le manque
d'argent il a fallu y aller aux jeux
c'est pareil on tape à poser dessus au
dessus de tout le monde n'en sait qu'à
un moment donné a failli se battre pour
y aller et ça commence de la formation
ça recommence de la junte arrive tu
postes là le premier jour tes fesses
dans son lit au centre de formation que
temps d'enlever ta famille à 14 15 ans
et que tu as cette passion affaires qui
ont envie de faire plaisir à tout le
monde j'ai envie d'y arriver c'est ce
chemin et à l'arrivée cha la récompense
mais comme je dis c'est une élite ses
trente quarante cinquante joueurs sans
peut-être 150 joueurs en france
la fille sont
la tête
les prochains
quelques-uns au téléphone et ils pensent
ils pensent beaucoup arrêté c'est
dommage parce que ils ont du talent ce
sont de bons joueurs donc notamment le
capitaine et qui a été viré à la fin de
l'année et qui se retrouve sans club
c'est vraiment dommage parce que c'est
un très très bon joueur et se retrouver
sans club comme ça c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment très difficile et intense et
c'est vraiment le métier de footballeur
qui voient ce à quoi c'est quand on
parle des pros qui touchent des sommes
astronomiques on ne dit pas le nombre de
joueurs qui ne réussissent pas et qui
ont gâché des études qui ont gâché un
peu leur vie par rapport au ballon donc
c'est un peu en contrepartie ce qui se
passe quoi donc
donc voilà pas tous réussiront pas tous
seront pro et et que tu vois aps la
plupart des thés des super joueurs qui
étaient en salle et je suis pas ils sont
pas poursuivies cet échec c'était
déception est beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
arrêtent le ballon parce qu'ils sont ils
sont déçus ce désistement du sport du
football sont vachement déçu et il
arrête il reste complètement alors que
la base j'ai fait ça comme moi j'ai fait
commence à 6 à 7 ans à vital sur un
terrain de foot comme un gamin de 8,10 à
d'ailleurs vécu chez un gamin je savais
que tu peux voir leurs hôtes et j'ai
justement le plus gamin de tout un pays
que je le plus âgé alors qu'elle
souhaitait garder cet amour du foot on
ne gardez pas parce que on a été déçu
c'est ce que j'essaye peu de répliquer
pour qu'il s'en sorte
cadets ces moments là la joie de route
est l'arbre à chat sur ce qu'on a de la
chance d'être là prennent conscience
vivre ces moments le plus plein avant
possible est et restera que ça après moi
moi c'est ma vision c'est ma vision des
choses de vous retrouver même temps
après et rediscuter de ces moments là on
a ce qui restera pont de ma carrière de
footballeur
et donne économique change elles
changent pour tous et elle change
forcément pour le foot jusqu'à
maintenant il n'y avait pas autant
d'argent parce qu'il est pas de droits
télé parce que le football européen
n'était pas autant de développer
par le biais des coupes d'europe des
ligues des champions et compagnie donc
ça a commencé là et puis et puis et puis
ça suit son chemin et ça n'arrêtait plus
que ça n'arrête plus mais forcément un
jour ça s'arrête
je pense que les années qui viennent
seront des années difficiles au plan
économique pas seulement pour le
football et les footballeurs
je pense qu'on est arrivé un peu au
sommet de la courbe montant des
transferts investissements divers et
variés et non je crois que plus que
jamais le centre de formation est
indispensable il faut dans les années
qui viennent on peut pas fixer de
pourcentage mais curieux cinq six
joueurs soient et constitue le noyau dur
de l'équipe et l'argent qui vous restent
si vous l'avez vous le consacrer à
essayer d'acheter la ou les deux ou
trois perles que le centre de formation
cette année là n'a pas pu vous fournit
donc cette c'est quelque chose qui à mes
yeux est essentiel c'est probablement le
plus important pour garantir l'avenir du
club
certainement je tâte je le verrais pas
peut-être je le verrai l'heure quand je
serai beaucoup plus vu encore mais voir
une équipe de l'om avec 50% de l'équipe
à l'identité mans c'est ça c'est si un
jour s'il ya un rêve que j'aimerais voir
se réaliser c'est celui-là 50% de
l'équipe s'est pas beaucoup d'effet sur
deux marseillais
pour la saison 2010-2011 sénat avec
sondeurs et jordan évolué sous contrat
pro avec l'espoir de jouer le plus
possible avec l'équipe première
malgré la proposition du club de
prolonger d'un an son contrat stagiaire
olivier a préféré signer avec le club de
marignane évolue en cfa nico quant à lui
s'est bien remis de sa blessure et
reprend à présent avec l'équipe réserve
en division d'honneur
c'est quoi l'enjeu ahmed enfin l'aînée
de ses jeunes joueurs restent encore et
toujours le grand frère de l'équipe des
minots
les galiciens